hey guys today we're going to examine
how the my hero academia timeline might
have changed
if obra shirakuma was never killed
during his second year at ua
for those that don't know this character
is someone who studied alongside
president mike nizawa
and their friendship was explored deeper
in the vigilante spin-off manga
if you're interested i did a separate
video explaining their backstory that
you can check out later
if you want to find out more about this
because those events fundamentally
changed who isawa became as a person
looking back ober's death had a massive
impact for both heroes and villains
and when i sat down to think about it it
was clear to me that things actually
turned out better with him being gone
i don't know if any of you been watching
loki recently but if shirokumu had
survived
it would have been the nexus event to
end all nexus events as the timing would
have branched off in the worst possible
way
in this video i'll break down why him
being alive opens up many awful
possibilities
including izawa not becoming a teacher
deku never receiving one for all
and all might having terrible things
done to him by all for one
before we begin be sure to like this
video and hit that sub button as we are
on the road to 400k subs so i would
genuinely
appreciate it a lot also manga spoiler
warning ahead as in order to explain
this stuff we do have to discuss content
from mikey academia and vigilantes
okay so starting with how shirokumo died
in the main timeline he and izawa were
doing a work study over the summer when
suddenly
a giant villain called garvey went on a
rampage several heroes tried and failed
to stop him
and among the fighting a building was
destroyed with the rubble then falling
down in the direction of these kids
had no one done anything then they
definitely would have all been crushed
but it was obro that used his cloud
quirk to save them
the cloud he created was dense enough to
protect them from the falling debris
but because he was so distracted he was
unable to avoid the rock that fell on
top of him
that was the facial blow that ultimately
killed him and the consequences of his
death would be felt all the way up till
the present day of the series
at some point before he was meant to be
cremated shurikumuma's corpse was stolen
by all for one
as he wanted to use the clockwork for
his own purposes by working with dr
garaki the two bad guys tinkered with
oprah's body and mind
until he became the intelligent no moon
on his kurogiri with multiple quirks
being fused into him
the original cloud ability was
transformed into one that could teleport
groups of people to specific coordinates
and as we've seen over the years this
has been crucial to the villain's plans
kikuragiri also served as a mentor and
also kind of like a butler to shigaraki
and he said that his mission in life was
to make sure the boy was okay which is a
personality trait that remained from
when he used to be shirokumo
back in ue shurikuma was always making
sure others weren't left behind
whether it was this abandoned cat that
he founded then temporarily adopted
or whether it was an unconfident teenage
izawa who he would constantly be trying
to cheer up
after oprah's death izawa gave up on his
dream of starting a hero agency with his
friends
and instead put all his energy into
training to become an independent
underground hero
it's implied that he trained virtually
non-stop for two years and upon
graduation he immediately left to start
doing his own thing
if oprah had survived there's absolutely
no chance things would have turned out
the same for both izawa and the league
so let's examine what might have
happened for argument's sake let's say
in this new timeline shurikuma made a
cloud that stopped the debris that was
meant to kill him
and after that he joined his friend in
the fight against garvey together they
would have certainly won this battle
considering that isar was able to win it
single-handedly in vigilantes
and with overall helping him the odds
would have only increased they knew how
to effectively use their quirks at the
same time
and after taking down this massive
villain isaac and shirakuma would get a
ton of great press
after all garvey was someone so powerful
that he took out multiple pro heroes
so for two students to defeat him i mean
that would be a story that would be
heard all across the country
this scenario is different to when
isabella beat garvey by himself as the
victory was overshadowed by the fact a
uh student actually died
in this new timeline they would have
gained the respect of a lot of people
including his purple highness
who was of course the hero they were
interning with his purple highness
already knew they had potential
but after these events and you know them
getting all this great press i think he
would have made them a permanent offer
to become his psychics after they
graduate
this would be an offer the boys wouldn't
refuse because it was literally part of
their existing life plan to work there
in the future anyway
and in chapter 62 they said they plan to
one day permanently join the purple
revolution agency
and then after that they would start
their own agency with president mike
his royal highness was especially known
for helping his trainees to go
independent and do their own thing
so like i said it's a no-brainer they
would accept this as it would help them
in their overall dream
moving on something i think is relevant
is that midnight was also a fellow
intern at the purple agency
in fact she was the one who got them
hired in the first place during the
manga shirakuma would blast virtually
every time he interacted with her
and yes some of those times might have
been because she was half naked but
crucially even when she was in full
school uniform this guy was still doing
it
again read chapter 62 of vigilantes and
you'll see clearly that he had his eyes
on her
and after defeating garvey he might have
had enough of an adrenaline rush to ask
her out
whether midnight would agree to that is
a different question but she did make a
point to say that she didn't want to be
single forever
and with both of them working at the
same agency i think that for once this
is a ship that actually had a chance of
happening
now when it comes to waisawa his
confidence was skyrocketed in the months
after the incident
as his self-belief would be higher than
it's ever been he always used to
perceive himself as a weak person with
an average quirk
but his work-study experience would have
proven he's the real deal to everyone
including himself
with the knowledge that he's now
guaranteed to become a sidekick it's
rational that shoto would try to improve
on the weaknesses that his future bosses
pointed out
in particular he told aizaw that he
drastically needed to improve his smile
and this is something i unironically
think he would have spent a lot of time
trying to master before he graduates ua
along with that he and shirakuma would
continue to train together in the joint
battles
and overall shoto would just be a much
happier person a lot of his serious
demeanor in the main timeline was shaped
by obero's death in the experiences that
came after that
however in this new timeline his
attitude would be completely different
and i think he'd be a lot more positive
but still humble
maybe similar to someone like ojuro or
maybe a more toned down version of
hiroshima
anyhow this is the point in the video
where things take a dark turn because
i'm going to break down why srirakuma
surviving isn't so great for society as
a whole
in chapter 270 of the main series dr
gregory revealed that back in the day
when he made kirigiri
he actually wanted isabella's a racia
quirk instead this lets us know that
shirokuma was not the first choice to be
turned into a nomu
and they only did it since his death
presented an opportunity but in reality
it was showter who was the preferred
option had obro never died
then it's probable the villains would
have hatched a plan to not only steal
erasure
but to turn izawa into a nomu that they
could use for years to come
in italy though this wouldn't be an easy
thing for the villains to accomplish as
capturing
a well-known ua student is bound to draw
unnecessary attention
if they kidnapped izawa then the heroes
would definitely put a team together to
search for him
which opens up the possibility of dr
garaki's secret lab being discovered
from afa's point of view that isn't
worth the risk so the best option for
success is to use gigantomachia
in a flashback we once saw that
gigantomachi was sent to find the
springer hero agency
only for his master to then show up with
the spring-like limbs quirk a few years
later
implying that makia is occasionally set
on these quirk stealing missions i
reckon once izawa becomes a permanent
sidekick at the purple revolution agency
maki will be ordered to attack it and
make sure shota is killed
with dr goraki's extensive medical
connections he can then gain access to
the body and swap it out prior to
cremation just like he did with
shirakumo
and by doing it this way it means that
no one will ever know a racehead's body
is in their possession
soon after shota's quirk factor would be
harvested by all for one
with the doctor making duplicate
versions that will be given to future
higher nomus
afo himself would take possession of the
original erasure quark
while the nomu aiza would be given a
copy of erasure along with other
abilities as well
the aim would be to experiment on him
until he turns into something resembling
kurogiri
as they would want an intelligent nomu
given that shirokumo never died in this
timeline the new kiraguri would have a
different set of powers that are based
around eurasia
such as maybe a quirk where he doesn't
have to blink because his eyes are
always hydrated
or maybe you know another one where he
gets to zoom in at people who are far
away
if you have any suggestions for what
type of quirks you might have then let
me know in the comments below
but remember it has to be related to
helping erasure and amplifying that
power
anyway in the main series alma and afo
fought around six years prior to the
first episode
however in this new timeline all for one
would fight him as soon as he gets his
hands on erasure
this quirk straight up changes
everything as afo could catch the symbol
of peace by surprise
erase one for all and then beat him to a
pulp with his multiple quirks
all might would have no clue that all
for one would have stolen nizam's power
so there wouldn't be time for him to
make a backup plan and also given that
cern aitai was never allowed to see his
future
neither of them would know what was
going to happen chapter 305 revealed
that all for one tried at least two
times in the past to steal one for all
and this is something he'd no doubt want
to try again the problem is that if he
really wants to steal it he needs to
have enough raw emotion to override the
will of the seven previous users
but for a sociopath like all for one
that is just impossible
just like in the main series he'd know
he has to rely on someone else to do it
for him
but at this point in the timeline
shigaraki would be way too young
to get around this the villains could
capture all might's half-conscious body
and restrain him underground
with izawa the nomu being tasked to
watch over him 24 7.
with aizawa watching all might would be
quirkless for the foreseeable future
and his ancient body would deteriorate
as time goes on to the outside world it
would seem like he disappeared without a
trace
but i think most people would assume
that all might abruptly retired because
in vigilantes they did say that many
heroes go into hiding when they're done
especially ones like all might who go
around making enemies of course not
everyone would believe that but
regardless his absence would lead to
japan gradually descending into chaos
as the country suffers a helpless all
knight would be locked away with his
quirk costly being erased
while afo would be busy raising a
successor who would be hateful enough to
override the spirits of one for all
this would take many years to accomplish
possibly over a decade or more
but eventually shiguraki could reach a
point where he is able to steal the
power
by the time this happens japan would
already be a chaotic and lawless place
just like all
one intended and by having shiggy take
one for all the villains will quite
literally be invincible
in this timeline i think the midoris
might have actually left the country to
live wherever the hell deku's dad has
been this whole time
as it would be way too dangerous for
them to stick around the remaining
heroes would likely try to maintain
some sense of order in the country but
even in the main series we saw how
quickly hero society can be torn apart
without all might villain groups such as
the shihisikai and liberation army will
continue to grow in influence
and it would be up to the old endeavor
to you know lead the heroes against
these enemies
i personally don't see that turning out
too well and once afo takes over
shiguraki's body then it would truly be
game over
with this new vessel he would have the
combined power of one floor and all for
one
not to mention an army of hyun nomu and
giganto makia
so whichever way you want to look at it
there will be no one powerful enough to
stop afo from turning japan into a
dictatorship
it's possible you might see foreign
heroes like captain celebrity trying to
intervene
but more likely anyone who would try to
defeat afo would be killed themselves
this is all a realistic possibility that
might have played out had shirokumo not
died back in the day
so maybe what happened to him in
vigilantes was a necessary evil
be sure to let me know down below what
you think might have happened and also
what quirks nomu aizaw would have gotten
and don't forget to hit that sub button
if you haven't already until the next
one
peace out